- Was that uncomfortable
though, being in that mask?
That was huge.
- What?
- Were you hot?
I would be sweating.
- I was hot as hell, yes.
It was like, so hot,
so kind of uncomfortable but
I wanted to be in that mask
and I wanted to be in that hard dress
and those pumps.
- Man, you are braver than I,
I look at my stylus, I'm
like, I feel like sausage,
I feel like I'm stuffed in
here, help me out, I'm like..
No but my sister and my
mother love that show.
- It's an awesome show.
- It's so big, it's so popular.
- Yes it is and I'm happy
to have been a part of it.
At 75, I do think that people don't think
75 women should do that.
- Did you say 75?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Guest] Oh yes.
- I have zero time for you
lookin' like that at 75.
- Oh thanks sweetheart.
- I can't stand you right now.